thomas bonsoir alors que faut-il retenir
de cette conférence de presse de sergueï
lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe
battue c'était une conférence de presse
très dense qui a duré près d'une heure
trente dans laquelle sergueï lavrov a
balayé un certain nombre de sujets
internationaux et en premier lesquels
évidemment il a été interrogé sur le
dossier de l'afghanistan le dossier qui
a animé l'actualité pendant tout l'été
alors le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a souligné le départ
précipité sans réflexion sur les
conséquences de la part des américains
en afghanistan et puis est venue la
question des relations entre moscou et
les talibans alors sergueï lavrov a
expliqué qu'il y avait des contacts
entre les deux mais qu' une
reconnaissance internationale du
gouvernement formé par les taliban
n'était pour le moment pas sur la table
et puis il a donc été interrogé plus
généralement sur le changement de
stratégie en tout cas en apparence de la
part des états unis faisant référence à
l'allocution de joe biden qui a eu lieu
un peu plus tôt cette semaine dans
laquelle elle joue haydn expliqué que
les guerres menées ces vingt dernières
années par les états unis à toucher à
leur fin de sergueï lavrov a donc été
interrogé sur ce changement de stratégie
en tout cas en apparence encore une fois
de la part de joe biden écoutez la
réaction de sergueï lavrov
après ce qu'a dit le président baden sur
le fait d'imposer par la force la
démocratie
peut-être qu'ils vont essayer d'autres
moyens
pour modifier l'avis d'autres vies
donc
encourager une révolution n'est pas
forcément l'emploi de la force donc donc
vous regardez ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres pays on en libye en iran en
syrie et d'un autre sur notre voisin le
cren par conséquent nous voudrions
effectivement que les états unis passent
à l'étape suivante et qu'ils arrêtent
d'employer la force et d'une manière
générale qui cesse de s'occuper des
éphèbes des autres
elle entendu beaucoup d'autres dossiers
internationaux en filigrane donc la
syrie l'iran ou encore la ligne et puis
est venue la question sur le mali
puisque hier jean-yves le drian avait
averti des conséquences graves de
l'implication éventuelle de la société
wagner au mali l'avait averti le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
et donc réaction attendue de la part de
sergey lavrov sur ce sujet je vous pose
là encore de l'écouter
les autorités de transition
continue d'ailleurs cette lutte contre
le terrorisme et dans cette optique ils
se sont adressés à des compagnies
armées privées
parce que la france a si j'ai bien
compris décidé de réduire
significativement sa présence militaire
donc les autorités maliennes ont estimé
que leurs forces étaient insuffisantes
sans aide extérieure
et comme l'aide de ceux qui aiment qui
s'était engagé à déraciner le
terrorisme donc bah du coup ils
s'adressent à des compagnies
militaires privées russes nous n'avons
rien à voir avec ça et cela ne concerne
que le gouvernement légitime ce qui est
considéré comme
les forces de transition légitime et
ceux qui proposent ce genre de services
mhcs
et puis autre dossier qui intéresse tout
particulièrement la dite si française
c'est évidemment la faire des sous
marins entre la france et l'australie de
plus généralement cette crise
diplomatique qui a agité cette semaine
ici aux nations unies et cette crise
diplomatique entre paris et washington
alors sergueï lavrov a expliqué que la
russie n'était pas directement impliqué
dans ce dossier mais que les
conséquences que cette affaire pouvait
avoir à sur la scène internationale en
revanche était surveillé de près par
moscou écoutez donc les précisions de
sergey lavrov qui a été interrogé sur la
position russe par rapport à cette crise
diplomatique entre paris et washington
cet événement
juste après la fuite de l'afghanistan
invite à se poser des questions sur ce
qui se passe au sein de l'alliance et je
comprends que j ai évidemment ils nous
font sur le plan commercial pour la
france mais ça veut dire est ce que ces
alliances sont fiables
est-ce que la l'autonomie stratégique de
l'europe est toujours d'actualité
évidemment pour
le le camp occidental c'est une question
grave qui se pose est et doivent la
réseau nous n'avons pas l'intention de
nous mêler de cette histoire mais les
conséquences de ce qui se passe
évidemment nous pouvons les ressentir et
cela peut influencer sur nos relations
avec eux l'union européenne alors parmi
les autres dossiers qui ont été abordés
lors de cette conférence de presse on
pourra notamment cité le cas de la
palestine ou encore de la corée sergueï
lavrov qui a plusieurs fois plusieurs
reprises appelé au dialogue des
différentes parties engagées dans ces
différents dossiers il est également
revenu suite à une question d'un des
journalistes sur cette guerre froide
comme elle est souvent présentée entre
washington et pékin là encore sans
regret lavrov a appelé à trouver des
compromis le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères qui devrait maintenant à
s'exprimer d'ici quelques instants à la
tribune de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies ici un mur merci beaucoup
thomas bonne et on va suivre a bien sûr
l'intervention un des ministres des
affaires étrangères russe à la tribune
de l'eau vous êtes bien dans direct de
new york et non pas le washington comme
je disais tout à l'heure merci à vous
thomas bon escient